come to have an operation that's a week
store big [ __ ] difference
we saw the smoke and he just shook he
shook cuz he knows what's coming tonight
and [ __ ]
you know who's at the door the grim
[ __ ] Reaper [ __ ]
it's the herb man he's free and he's
coming to [ __ ] get high with you if
you're Nadine get off this [ __ ]
periscope right now [ __ ] cuz
uncle Joey and his goon barley sciatic
low and heat Chanukah is over Monica's
over that's it it's over Yom Kippur next
year when all those [ __ ] Jew holiday
it's over [ __ ]
[Music]
Joey what type of little [ __ ] cloud
smoke so they know there's something
wrong with the [ __ ] bong I tried to
fix it
but it's a beautiful day to be alive
you're here it's the Church of what's
happening now the pre Church periscope
let me tell you something it's a
beautiful day to be alive it's raining
we're here we got a help who's better
than [ __ ] you you're sitting around
it's the beginning of the year Trump who
gives a [ __ ] from pump the Russians it's
you and me against the world [ __ ]
understand me
[Music]
there we go
my grandpa from The Munsters always on
point like a [ __ ] Jackie
understand me
plus we got the animals of death tonight
as usual we're gonna open up with 6:00
tonight we're gonna live for the [ __ ]
jugular we open up with 12 ones you just
look for solidarity I'm saying this is
it you don't want to stand up for the
flag eat six dollars then get your
Excuse hey you go two for two that's one
six count them with me one two just like
that buckle my shoe [ __ ]
uncle Joey's back while the [ __ ]
darkness and it's time to podcast
[ __ ]
I got some beautiful new reefer today
this is the reefer reefers this is
[ __ ] the new perennial oh my goodness
it looks like Martian reefer look at
this [ __ ] thing this is the real
Martian [ __ ] right here [ __ ] you [ __ ]
Star Wars [ __ ] Gary fish I don't give a
[ __ ]
this is the real [ __ ] Star Wars right
here find it one more [ __ ] worried
about Gary fishing you know why cuz it's
that [ __ ] homo movie star wars one
minute will you watch in Star Wars that
explains your Scientologists cut the
[ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] about Martians and
everything I live right here Brad alert
[ __ ] get your [ __ ] together all we
carry fresh and Carrie Fisher Carrie
Fisher what about George Michael you
don't think he has an uncle that
molested him where's that button uncle
Sean picture but no all [ __ ] week boy
a day that Gary's [ __ ] you'll give us a
puppy daddy [ __ ] I've had enough
already and now put him in a [ __ ]
grave what do I give a [ __ ] all week
Carrie Fisher Carrie Fisher she was some
[ __ ] big dealing [ __ ] George Michaels
dead we sang freedom [ __ ] Carrie Fisher
I'm sorry got emotional using said no he
annexed the Babe Ruth he said [ __ ] the
shirt with the buttons it's over no more
buttons got the beg you Gentiles in your
[ __ ] Star Wars I never watch that
piece of [ __ ] I hate all those [ __ ]
movie
rogue one yet we might as well put a
dick up your ass if you camping out for
[ __ ] Star Wars that's what the
problem is then you reach then your
Wonder you sit there why do people join
Scientology
why do people vote for Trump these are
the same [ __ ] people these are the
same [ __ ] people why do people vote
for Hillary same [ __ ] people stand on
line you [ __ ] together his [ __ ]
[Music]
you thought we were just done we got
some transmission fluid chocolate comes
in tomorrow
you're [ __ ] okay till next Tuesday
but you better be training while I'm out
of town Lisa yeah let me tell you
something when the stars meet [ __ ]
TKO this is like Godzilla meat and
[ __ ] the smart monster you understand
me the greatest Godzilla movies of all
time Japanese people everywhere yeah
you understand me so next time you want
to see the devil I'm gonna show up for
the [ __ ] cookie enough show with a
[ __ ] TKO look at this right here
60 minutes guaranteed activation who
makes that [ __ ] promise and one hour
you will be seeing the devil in
different [ __ ] colors you understand
me in case you're diverse you want to
see the red devil the black devil how
come there's not an Indian that well eat
one of these you'll see a Hindu [ __ ] at
them you'll have a dot the [ __ ]
lottery ticket everything understand me
[ __ ] you think you're dealing with the
light [ __ ] let me tell how strong this
thing is it's even greasy on the outside
of the [ __ ] box this transmission
fluid is the cheese it right here
people been dying out here in California
you're sitting there your house oh my
god or my life listen [ __ ]
hitchhiking car and come to Cali and
we'll get you one of these and you'll
see the [ __ ] light [ __ ] you
understand me uncle Joey coming at you
direct January 4th from the Voodoo
Lounge listening to the [ __ ] doors
and whatnot lettuce you pop this thing
out like this
hmm hmm the transmission I could go home
and spit on my daughter's bicycle chain
and Oh be greasy as [ __ ] in the stand me
there's no talking about you bad
[ __ ] who's doing about him
you are just like that ice swallows
[ __ ] thing hope my intestines are
[ __ ] savages you understand me
that's where I go to yoga a couple days
a week if [ __ ] are your testosterone
levels but if [ __ ] hope it's good for
your tummy it helps you [ __ ] break
down the edibles
[ __ ] you and Carrie Fisher concept is
you can all suck my dick what about
George Michael what about Prince Noah
they're doing a twenty20 enough enough
already
we want Dimas smoke somebody I sit there
[ __ ] the stairs and I smoke some [ __ ]
reefer cuts
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
and you thought this is gonna be a
ho-hum night you thought you were gonna
drive grandmother's shop right [ __ ]
and it's all over [ __ ] uncle Joey
came into your life like I said if
you're Nadine hang up now [ __ ] cab
y'all periscope I've seen are you doing
bong it's in kindergarten I don't need
that [ __ ] let's do another bong ahead
way of doing I hope you guys are well I
hope you start a year off
Humpty [ __ ] Dumpty
[Music]
get up yet I got chocolate bag
that's for mid-show we don't know
nothing about nothing understand me
not in the pot not in [ __ ] well
you ready for the bond of death will put
some leaves in him gonna give me a mix
of different reefers there you go
because I want you to be the man of many
reefers they got my friends going deep
with that we from the Antichrist nice
beautiful but could leave with his food
up roots of fight shirt on oh [ __ ] I
want to thank them for sending us a box
of shirts roots of look at this [ __ ]
right here ain't [ __ ] around here you
understand me I look good in navy blue
that's right [ __ ] you bad
[ __ ]
I'm in a good time with you people I
missed you I don't see you for a few
days I start missing you come loose a
casino is [ __ ] sold out but I'll tell
you what Cleveland there's still tickets
available next Thursday's the party
[ __ ] Nino stories
[Music]
look at that huh this is really the
[ __ ] end friend the end
[Music]
[Music]
this [ __ ] steaks it's Nick the Greek
is [ __ ] takes care your week with nice
chicken cutlets with artichoke sauce
beautiful I'm excited about Cleveland
next week we got a show on Thursday
through Friday through Saturday the
second show Friday
Steve Bay is coming out o be in the
audience got a table gonna be rocked and
[ __ ] Cleveland you understand me
what
[Music]
look at me look at you bad [ __ ]
those are real clouds of joy you
understand me
I'm happy you [ __ ] made it out do it
it's gonna be that type of night the
Church of what's happening now is a
state of [ __ ] mind understand it's
like being a Jew it's a state of mind
you don't live it you help people in
need
[ __ ] a little people floating around I'm
not talking about those guys at 7-eleven
[ __ ] them go out and spiel for a living
like I had are you [ __ ] you got
any balls you got a BB gun or something
and put it to good use
you're out there hasn't change [ __ ] you
packs up this go out there focus get a
notebook write your goals I'm not
sleeping in a tree no more I'm moving up
to a park dad she [ __ ] don't give a [ __ ]
I slept in [ __ ] bus stations I slept
at the [ __ ] Park now here we are done
it the one thing you cook people either
get a heavy [ __ ] winter jacket I was
I was sleeping in Jersey in the parking
[ __ ] November [ __ ] jacket cuddle up
and car we ahead let the heat [ __ ]
resurface them after an hour you'll be
fine you toughen up like a [ __ ]
marine
pain and struggle is a [ __ ]
people that's it that's that you
understand me
the church is a state of mind you get up
in the morning you [ __ ] get out of
the house ain't nothing gonna happen on
TV get out of the [ __ ] house even if
you got a coffee shop put on a tab
tell them put me on a tad to Friday
things happen by Friday when you put in
your mind things will happen by Friday
put a gun to your [ __ ] head front an
8-ball tell the guy 300 on Friday watch
how motivated you get hey that's
motivation [ __ ] when you get that 81
you still gotta show up with the 250 on
Friday and you got to do what you got to
do because you gotta pay him and how you
think sometimes fine if you don't have
no blow so think about it
[Music]
I'm like a [ __ ] genie you know I'm
saying look at that but the only Jeannie
you got three wishes
I got always suck my dick that's my
[ __ ] wish [ __ ] it's a
beautiful night to get together timely
you're ready for bottling you live
sitting there the pipes are open the
mule is kicking look at this bar in here
you bad [ __ ] I love you people
[Music]
right the snake
oh [ __ ] is on talking about here bomb
hipster your lungs are in de member
month ago he couldn't do training
training [ __ ] like the Americans
you gotta train every day you want to do
big pockets you have two big pockets
every [ __ ] day that's it it's like
the old adage if you got checks you got
cash if you got checks in that thing you
got money [ __ ] you take a chance come
on mister can't do it no more they got
cameras you know people ask for three
IDs it's [ __ ] up one more Barnett what
do you think people stepped at you it's
that type of [ __ ] night you know I'm
saying you got to break out of your
comfort zone you got to hit voices
where's the last time you have voices
you haven't that's why I gotta hit
voices Monday your invoices I have
learned Boise is in a couple of days I
could still smell the transmission fluid
from that [ __ ] edible that's how
strong that goddamn [ __ ] edible is you
understand
[Music]
how's that motherfucker's just like a
Paco's Knight comes out with a cloud of
smoke this [ __ ]
come over here dropping movies on you
smoking reefer edibles when you get this
type of information from Jeff go [ __ ]
yourself even Jeff you don't give me
this type information what you gonna do
with your life and I have no idea what I
do with mine that's why that's right
Jeff don't you ever sit down much
jeopardy need to watch it for a week you
out that might drop and blows another
smell [ __ ] you know what the opera is
called you know a bunch of stupid [ __ ]
that don't get you know if it does it
does is you start dropping operas in
places in Africa people like that [ __ ]
white people they like that [ __ ]
oh you're so intelligent meanwhile he
flies out a LAX tips like me a flight of
[Music]
those lebombo planes flop you people go
down ritchie valens bunch of
[ __ ] Roberto Clemente I don't
like those lebombo planes I like a big
plane if I go down I go down with 20
people behind me yelling screaming [ __ ]
it I'm saying so beautiful mind happy
new you don't forget the Cuban Christmas
is Saturday and it's cash only
so no show up with no [ __ ] [ __ ]
blew it again
can't play [ __ ] cards twice he
doesn't know that it's 20% it's ticket
his first next big win I'm right there
will it calculator the [ __ ] pencil
isn't for nothing I got the date from
the visor and a visor I'll collect to
that 20 points it's actually usually get
for a [ __ ] state but this [ __ ] guy
lost ouzo and two two times I say [ __ ]
anyway youtube.com slash Church /c /
Joey Diaz youtube.com slash c / Joey DS
but coming into your [ __ ] living room
[ __ ] you know why cuz I love you
[ __ ] with all my heart without
you I'd have dick don't forget Cleveland
next week the party starts a week from
tomorrow
Thursday Friday Saturday no we got there
that I'm in Tempe but we're gonna
[ __ ] Rock and Cleveland first I'm
bringing the winter jacket I'm bringing
the [ __ ] pistols it's all over the
streets of [ __ ] Cleveland understand
me here we go Jim Morrison tailored for
the next level oh [ __ ] there's a CIA
music right here oh [ __ ]
[Music]
it's a nice night people sit back relax
let your mind to get the notebook out
get the feather with the blood and write
your manifesto you understand me
this is my [ __ ] [ __ ] manifesto
with [ __ ] manifestos Bester's look up
man anyway I'll see you in [ __ ] 15
minutes and we'll get this party set on
break all right [ __ ] look at
this [ __ ] huh this is a great [ __ ]
out
[Music]
come on baby take a chance with us
[ __ ] tremendous people
what
[Music]
good you need something get your heart
don't [ __ ] come on baby take a
chance with us
alright 15 minutes we'll be back I love
you [ __ ] thank you for the
periscope thank you for the love you
know bro you know how we do it here is
the real [ __ ] deal stay black